bon au niveau financier madame chalu
comment ça se passe pour vous bon ben
pour ma maman la retraite étant autour
de 1100 € il manque 8 ou 900 € par mois
par mois d'accord mettons mettons 1000 €
par mois ça fait 12000 € par an fois 10
ans ça fait 120000 € pour une personne
pour une personne et de grosses sommes
de grosses
oui bonjour pesbon député de la 2e
circonscription du puit d'Ô en juillet
dernier donc j'ai remis à la première
ministre un rapport à sa demande sur le
reste à charge en établissement en épad
pour les
résidents c'est dans le puits de daô
autour de la ville de rillon dans sa
circonscription que la députée
socialiste Christine pierrezbon a été
interpellé par des familles qui
n'arrivaient plus à payer la place en
épad de leurs parents et elle a cherché
à savoir comment fonctionnait le système
vousz bien bonjour ça va bien merci à
pas à location logement aide sociale les
familles sont soutenues mais le reste à
charge comme on dit est souvent
important 2100 € ici chaque mois c'est
Marie c'est le rapport sur le reste à
charge en N pas qui qui nous conduit ce
matin à venir vous voir ben vous êtes la
bienvenue comme toujours vous avez
combien de résidents on a 68 résidents
68 parmi eux Antonia arrivé ici il y a 2
ans elle pas froid depuis ces enfants
doivent se serrer la ceinture pour payer
chaque mois surtout que paradoxalement
les plus modestes sont les moins aidé
bonjour
bonjour bonjour madame madame on est à
peu près à 1100 € de rest à charge voilà
à divisé en personnes en on est h frères
et sœurs on règle chacun 136 € par
personne par mois ou actuellement je
suis sans
emploi donc forcément avec mes
charges locative résidentielle et cetera
c'est une charge supplémentaire qui qui
est pas négligeable sachant
qu'aujourd'hui en plus je suis non
imposable j'ai pas
d'avantage fiscal contrairement à ma
sœur par exemple qui peut avoir une
petite déduction d'imposition
effectivement si votre maman était à
domicile vous auriez toutes les deux
tous les h d'ailleurs une aide une aide
fiscale qu'on appelle un crédit d'impôt
alors que quand on est en établissement
seul les personnes imposables donc quand
on est imposable c'est qu'on a un peu
plus de moyens que quand on ne l'est pas
parce que quand on paye des impôts c'est
qu'on a plus de moyens que celui qui
n'en paye pas là contreintuitivement on
a une aide une aide fiscale donc c'est
vrai que c'est particulièrement
injuste plus de 3/4 des résidents enpad
peuvent payer ce reste à charge sans
vendre leurs biens et surtout faire
appel à leurs
enfants pour la député il est temps de
tout revoir pour rendre le système plus
juste et plus simple
aussi en fait aujourd'hui on a des un
système d'aide beaucoup trop compliqué
avec quatre aides pour 5 milliards
d'argent public quand même donc on a de
l'argent public pour aider les gens sauf
que c'est incompréhensible pour les
résidents c'est incompréhensible pour
les familles et donc plutôt que d'avoir
ce maquis de S en financier et ben je
propose une seule aide universelle
c'est-à-dire pour tous les résidents en
éepad et qui est dégressive en fonction
des des revenus tout simplement pour
soulager les familles quand les gens
vivent toujours plus âgés Christine
pirzbaone veut créer une sorte de
bouclier au bout de 3 ou 4 ans les
descendants ne seraient plus mis à
contribution et la solidarité national
prendrait totalement en charge le prix
de
l'Pad car le système actuel donne lieu à
des situations
hubuesques quand les familles ne
s'entendent pas dans certains
département les petits enfants peuvent
être mis à
contribution je me souviens il y a
quelques années c'était des petits
enfants ils sont venus me parler de
cette obligation alimentaire qu'il
comprenaient pas quoi et qui était
compliqué en
plus à gérer pour eux parce qu'ils
avaient des enfants en basâge ils
avaient pas de gros salaires ils
travaillaient tous les deux ils avaient
des salaires nor mot on va dire mais
c'était compliqué les enfants ne
touchant que de petites retraitees les
petits enfants furent sollicités donc il
y a pas eu d'accord de la famille donc a
sisine du juge aux affaires familiales
qui tranche et qui leur avait
demandé 100 € par mois donc c'est vrai
que pour eux c'était c'était in
compréhensible voilà sachant
que que la dame en question avait trois
enfants ce qui est très paradoxal c'est
que cette dame avait une maison en fait
qui aurait pu être vendue alors
apparemment elle avait un bien qui
aurait pu effectivement être vendu mais
pour être vendu il faut effectivement
que les enfants soient d'accord et donc
ils étaient évidemment pas d'accord pour
vendre ce bien parce qu'il savaiit
pertinemment qu'au moment de de
l'héritage il leur reviendrait
voilà dans sa volonté de réformer le
système la députée socialiste a obtenu
une première victoire il y a quelques
jours seulement j'ai retrouvé ce que je
voulais la semaine dernière donc dans le
cadre de la loi bien vieillir à
l'Assemblée nationale à
l'unanimité on a voté l'article qui met
fin à l'obligation alimentaire pour les
petits
enfants comme le montre le rapport de la
députée le prix moyen du reste à charge
en épad est de 2000 € aujourd'hui en
France avec de grandes disparités selon
les régions 1600 € pour la haute zone
plus de 3500 € pour Paris ou les hautes
scènes et parfois le sentiment de ne pas
en avoir pour son argent ici à l'épadre
rattaché à l'hôpital public de rillon
Brigitte chalu est un peu la
porte-parole des famille pour chaque
personne âgée c'est 2000 € on visite la
maison de retraite avec le directeur ma
maman ma
tata bonjour on voit les
locaux c'est pas mal voilà c'est pas mal
félicitation du
jury Brigitte chalu est ironique car en
réalité la maison de retraite est disons
dans son jus depuis les années 70 avec
des équipements plus fatigués encore que
les résidents eux-mêmes
bonjour vous avez un ascenseur qui est
étroit déjà et qui fonctionne pas tout
le temps la dernière fois que j'étais
venue en P la dernière fois qu'on le
répare après les plus réparable d'accord
et quand vous avez un seul enseur dans
les pad qui tomb en panne vous faites
tout avec la force des jambes et des
bras et ça c'est compliqué un personnel
en difficulté des locaux
vitust autant dire que cela a des
conséquences sur le bien-être des
personnes
donc là c'est la douche du premier étage
voil une seule douche combien de
chambrees il y a deux douches pour 68
résidents d'accord une au premier une au
trè ce qui fait que c'est une douche par
semaine pour chaque résident le RES du
temps c'est des toilettes au lavableau
d'accord voilà une douche par semaine
dans le meilleur des cas quand tout
fonctionne heureusement tout cela sera
bientôt du passé car les pades va
totalement être refait à neuf le projet
consiste en la reconstruction 230 lit
d'pad en lieu place de l'Pad des jardins
et de l'Pad pasteur vous voyez ici donc
lespad des jardins existant et ici
l'actuel parking du personnel Brigitte
chalu a du mal à se réjouir car au total
l'investissement s'élève à plus de 21
millions d'euros un coup qu'il va bien
falloir répercuter sur le prix que
chaque résident paye tous les
mois globalement c'est une dizaine
d'euros
supplémentair sur les journ héberg par
jour donc donc c'est conséquent donc par
mois ça fait donc par mois ça fait 300
c'est déjà compliqué aujourd'hui donc là
si on a une augmentation trop
conséquente il y a des personnes qui ne
pourront pas rester à l'p suron la RS va
donner une subvention de 4 millions
d'euros si le département met aussi la
main au portefeuille cela pourrait faire
baisser la facture mais pour épargner
les familles la députée pense que ce
n'est pas assez ce que j'ai écrit dans
le rapport c'est qu'effectivement que ce
soit des projets de de restructuration
des projets de construction des projets
d'humanisation plus vous mettez de
subventions et pas de d'avance
remboursable de subvention plus vous
maîtrisez le reste à charge parce que
moins vous aurez de frais financiers
évidemment et euh et plus le reste à
charge pourra être maîtrisé par par les
équipes en
place en réalité peu d'épad arrivent à
maîtriser leur coût ici en Auvergne
ronalp 85 % des établissements affichent
des déficit en fin d'année mais il y a
des contreexemples et la députée veut
s'en inspirer dans son travail nous
sommes à 60 km de ClermontFerrand et
cette maison de retraite est classée 3oè
meilleure de France pour le bien-être de
ses résidents parmi les 7400 de notre
pays bonjour vous allez bien bien
merci Salut Didier merci de nous
accueillirenue à l'p de
J mais en plus cette épad a une
situation financière saine ce qui lui
permet de maintenir les coups on va voir
nos
résidents bonjour tout le
monde pour réussir le tour de force de
maintenir les coups tout en apportant
une qualité de service lespad a tout
misé sur son
vous faites quoi là aujourd'hui alors
chambou chambou
tout quant ailleurs on peine à trouver
du personnel ici les salariés restent
longtemps et l'absentéisme est quasi
nul chez nous les animatrices c'est pas
je juste réalise le chamboule tout c'est
des animations individuelles le matin où
elles vont voir tous les résidents qui
peuvent pas participer aux animations
collectives elles vont faire du du
massage la lecture des discussions et
plein d'autres
choses le fait d'être là depuis
longtemps ou d'avoir assez de personnel
pour tout le monde c'est sûr que c'est
l'idéal c'est c'est ce qu'il y a de
mieux pour les résidents quoi c'est sûr
que quand on regarde ailleurs c'est
c'est tout l'opposé chouchouter ses
salariés c'est vertueux pour les
finances de la maison de retraite et
donc pour cell des
résidents on y gagne tous les points de
vue en fait un personnel même si c'est
après un personnel qui du coup monte des
échelons et
valorisé c'est toujours beaucoup moins
cher queun interhumire qu'il faut
rémunérer quand même presque deux fois
plus que un personnel soignant
basiqueen ici on a fait des choix
différents de la majorité des épades on
a ni psychologue ni médecin
coordonateurs mais deux animatrices à
temp plein pour 39 résidents seulement
soignante qui fait un groupe patoi et
ils souviennent de leur tradition ce
qu'il faisaent avant la députée
préconise de chercher de nouvelles
sources de financement comme le rapport
Libo avant elle elle estime qu'il manque
10 milliards d'euros par an pour la
dépendance on parle beaucoup de la
transition énergétique mais l'autre
l'autre mur qui est devant nous c'est la
transition démographique et le nombre de
personnes on a eu un baby boom et ben on
va avoir un baby boom on va l'avoir et
donc on le sait c'est pas des projets
c'est une réalité qui est documentée qui
est sûre et donc il faut que les
pouvoirs publics dégagent les moyens
financiers ça passera effectivement par
des recettes supplémentaires il y a pas
d'argent magique mais ça passera par des
recettes supplémentaires passez une
bonne
soirée Christine pi espère que les
éléments de son rapport seront repris
dans la loi à grand
âge que le gouvernement a promis de
faire voter en
[Musique]